Hey Youtubers, the
year of hype is started, so Kylo Ren, teasing
his character in episode 8 let's break it
down there is a new round of the Star Wars
giveaway it's for IMAX get certificates.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
So what he's saying here that is like a Lucasfilm
person off in the distance that you can see
with the sniper rifle on them.
Just careful not to spoil super big plot points
he actually says a bunch of stuff, so number
10 he's basically saying we're going to see
Kylo Ren's humanity in episode 8.
Meaning that we might get like a full-blown
redemption of Kylo arc by the end of the series
which might not be a huge surprise like he
goes into this big speech about the original
conception of the character with the producers
how they wanted to show a bunch of people
tackling the same problem of bringing order
to a galaxy and chaos from to balance perspectives
now use the word balance, but the first-order
just totally came off like fascist they massacred
a bunch of people with the giant death Star
weapon.
He even killed his father.
So even though the first-order Kylo Ren soaker
deftly the antagonists of the new trilogy
they're going to do a good job of providing
a balanced perspective like why it is the
Kylo Ren believes that what they're doing
is the right way of doing things.
So number nine.
Bringing order to a galaxy and chaos very
Darth Vader original trilogy approach to what
Kylo Ren is doing now, which makes sense because
he's a Vader Fanboy he carries the melted
helmet around with him the ashes that he puts
it in their direction the ashes of the people
that he's defeated let that detail out of
the movie but it just as you know how hardcore
he is, but those are invaders ashes just that
helmet belongs to Vader number 8 talking about
some more the context that he said that they're
going to be adding how did he come to be with
supreme leader's note.
So they actually explain a little bit of that,
during the expanded materials in the books
that they released like if you bought one
of the look books next to learn a little bit
more about the characters than you would in
the movie, so they describe Kylo Ren is someone
that has an identity crisis growing up just
because of who his family as his parents are
big part of the resistance forming this new
government the galaxies kind of in chaos.
So he himself has an identity crisis and in
that moment of weakness supreme leader's note
seeks them out and takes advantage of him,
just like a cult leader would feeding and
promises giving him the feeling of purpose
and family that he felt like he wasn't getting
from his real family that is Adam driver describes
him like he still feels the pole of the light
side, so number seven.
Why did he have to kill Han Solo in the movie,
the biggest reason for that is that his family
was a big tether for him to the light side
of the force.
He wanted to get rid of that.
So he felt like he had to kill his father
although really it was snow pushing him in
that direction and a reverse version of what
Luke Skywalker had to go through like the
tests that he had to face Vader and confront
the idea that he was his father like you to
come to terms with that.
That was one of the final test on his path
to becoming a Jedi not just fighting Darth
Vader, but also coming to terms with who Vader
was and what that meant about himself about
Luke.
So Kylo Ren had a reverse version of that.
So when he is having this speech with Obi-Wan
Kenobi getting ready to go to a cloud city
to save his friends Kylo Ren has the same
version of that speech was supreme leader's
note here were he kind of feigns the problem
like oh this is going to be a big test for
you.
You've never faced anything like this.
Even though you're the master of the nights
of rent something droid we seek to support
the all show you last night's subject to post
which she so you could argue that Kylo Ren
didn't totally pass his test in the way that
Luke didn't totally pass his test either like
he came out of it with one less hand and just
could barely process the idea that Darth Vader
was his father so Kylo Ren is able to kill
Han Solo but that is a magically cut them
off from the light side of the force.
JJ Abrams did explain after the movie came
out that it is sort of like wounded him in
a spiritual way.
So it weakened him because it was such a heinous
act.
So that kind of informed his lightsaber fight
with Ray at the end like he was weak and spiritually
from killing Han Solo but he also got hit
with the bow caster blast.
So he was physically wounded.
So he was like gravely wounded even though
did really come across with the performance
like you kinda get the sense that is wounded,
but he's a Vader Fanboy, so number six.
Now that he's done this.
He's going to dig his heels in and double
down on the dark side of the force, even though
the light side is a totally dead inside of
remember organist see his humanity.
Meaning that there's so humanity in him there
still.
The light side of the force inside of them
so redemption of Kylo Ren, so number six more
context there just so much we don't know about
what precipitated what's happening in episode
seven.
We get flashes of it when Ray touches Anna
cannon's lightsaber we flashback to the Jedi
Academy massacre you see Kylo Ren with the
nights of rent it looks like they come back
after some absence.
He has his red light saber, so whatever's
happened he's taken on his Darkside persona
and come back to get rid of the Jedi in the
way that Anakin came back in massacred all
the children of the Jedi Temple.
So whereas with episode three you sort of
saw all the moments leading up to that you
saw the Emperor tell him to go take care of
the youngling's like he basically told him
go kill all these people you didn't really
see that with Kylo Ren's character so we'll
get some more context for that led up to that
moment white as he left the Jedi Temple if
supreme leader's note is such an evil person
Luke Skywalker would probably be aware of
him and keep him away from the Jedi.
So there a lot of character beats and story
beats as well that episode seven skipped over
that episode 8 will add context for speaking
of which number five the nights of rent, so
everybody is wondering about them with the
way they explain it is that they're not sift
but it's basically like another aspect of
the religion of the force like they introduced
the idea the church of the force Rogue one
actually took a more religious perspective
of the force itself.
So just like all religions have their deities
everyone has like very different ways of worshiping
the force and using it.
So the nights of rent is just meant to be
like another Darkside spinoff in the way that
the Sith which is like another sect of Darkside
users, but a lot of your wondering like we
saw that really bad ass castle on most of
far the belongs to Vader.
It was built on the ruins of an ancient Sith
temple or an ancient structure that was very
strong in the dark side of the force, so would
make sense that Kylo Ren would start reach
Reading a lot of Darth Vader's path, just
because he so obsessed with them.
He's almost on the exact same mission with
the exact same plan that Darth Vader was on.
So even if we don't see it in episode 8.
I would be surprised if it some point during
his training.
He visited that place.
But we'll see wherever it is the nights of
rent or actually finishing their training
because that's what Snopes says at the end
of episode seven.
He tells general hooks to get Kylo Ren bring
him to me.
So that we can finish his training the collapse
of the place since come to his time just so
number four what is snowcapped trying to do
with Kylo Ren, what is that train was the
whole point of it.
So the way they explain it like all the expanded
materials the look books is that he's trying
to create a super Jedi from a fallen light
side Jedi because he feels someone touched
by the light side could ultimately become
a more powerful Jedi than someone who is just
a purely Darkside force user.
So if you didn't read the expanded universe
books.
There was a character called Jason.
So he was one of the twins born to Han and
Leah who became something of a super Jedi
himself by learning to harness both the dark
side and the light side of the force, so they
call it the unifying force is like a much
more broader perspective of how the force
works in the kind of doing that on rebels
a little bit the season but they called the
Bendu Jedi is not all once is get dark Jedi
on one side you have like it on the other
the Bendu is in the middle and has a slightly
broader perspective of what the forces.
So yes note wants to subjugate the galaxy
the way the Emperor does bring it under control,
but he also wants to create a super Jedi.
So you wonder if like he and Ray are on parallel
arcs.
If the same thing is going to happen from
Ray's perspective give shall be pulled to
the dark side of the force in the both become
these crazy Jedi that will both the dark side
and the light side of the force number three.
Speaking of which, what is the history between
Kylo Ren and Ray because he definitely knew
who she was when he learned that they were
on just to the two were accompanied by go
what Sheila he freaked out at the thought
of a girl of force user.
So he probably knew her at the Jedi Academy
she seems like she's quite a bit younger.
So like when he's here massacring all these
Jedi she's like the little girl here, that
they drop off on Jaiku.
So on the surface you know still pending what
her true identity is it seems like they just
knew each other the Academy and she survived
the massacre and he's upset about that but
there all kinds of theories about who Ray's
parents are maybe she's related to Obi-Wan
Kenobi.
Somehow maybe she's related to the skywalkers
so the lad more context for that as well.
She came to be left on Jaiku by herself because
presumably if she was going to be hiding out
on some desert planet they would leave her
in the care of someone like an Obi-Wan figure
someone to watch over her from a distance
and she really didn't have that like they
were people, the kind of look out for.
Make sure she didn't die but she didn't have
it Obi-Wan Kenobi like Luke Skywalker had
number two what about supreme leader's note
where was he went all the stuff during the
original trilogy was happening because he
looks very old twisted by the Darkside.
So just like the Emperor.
He was very strong in the force, but if all
the stuff was happening with the Emperor in
the Empire during the original trilogy what
was snowed doing so based on the way the expanded
material describes him.
He was just kind of waiting for his opportunity.
He has a different approach to the dark side
of the force.
And the Emperor had so he was just off practicing
his force magic off in a different part of
the galaxy just watching all this chaos unfold
waiting for the galaxy to crumble.
So you just walk in cherry pick the stuff
that he wanted which included the remanence
of the empire which became the first order
and then Kylo Ren that they said that he had
a long-time fascination with the Skywalker
lineage so when he saw the opportunity to
nap one of the Skywalker children someone
who flowed from the lineage of Darth Vader.
He took it.
So wasn't like he just stumbled upon Kylo
Ren like he just been waiting for an opportunity
to take him from his family number one what
is this mean about endgame and when we actually
going to get some footage.
So the funny stuff is little bit easier to
explain Mark Hamill tease that he's going
to give a first look at episode 8 on his show
pop-culture request he didn't say when that's
can happen sometime soon.
Presumably, but I think the actual footage
won't drop till Star Wars celebration in the
spring.
So just set your calendars for that for like
an actual trailer get hype it's gonna be awesome
if 2016 was the year of zero children 2017
is going to be the year of hype.
So I'll say congratulations to the latest
Star Wars giveaway winner Ulysses Atkins you
and a pair of IMAX gift certificates be sure
to private message me on the back and my channel
so I can get your contact details.
There is a new round that started in this
video so because my next video will be Star
Wars, Princess Leia will just announce the
winner when I post that what you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for my
Thor Ragnarok plan Hulk preview and you can
click here for all my Rogue one Easter eggs
and you so much watching I'll see you guys
in the next video!